hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine
lieben Freunde nachdem Peyton also meine
Ex-Freundin und ich uns vor ca 3 Wochen
getrennt haben haben mir einige Mädels
einige die Ems geschrieben auf Instagram
und das ist ähm teilweise ein bisschen
verstörend gewesen von daher dachte ich
mir wir schauen uns heute mal gemeinsam
einige Anmachsprüche an die ich von euch
zugeschickt bekommen habe
es kann nur beschissen werden ich bin
zwar kein Magier aber ich würde dich
gerne mal in der Kiste zerlegen
man muss sagen kreativ ist der Spruch
nein wollte gerade deiner neuen Freundin
bei insta folgen aber da stand irgendwas
mit Profil bearbeiten ist auch gut ich
habe die zwar rausgesucht alle über die
letzten zwei drei Wochen aber die jetzt
gebündelt hier noch mal alle
nacheinander zu sehen ist schon
interessant would you mind filling in
this servey for my Records und dann
einen Screenshot von Ihrem iPhone
Kontakt einspeichern das hat mir no joke
ein Mädel aus Australien geschickt und
es war auch kein Fake Account ich weiß
nicht wie man in Australien auf die Idee
kommt sich mein beschissenen Content
anzugucken aber hey how are you have
nice Känguru bist du das heutige Datum
denn du bist eine 12 von 10
wahrscheinlich wollte sie das einfach
schon am 10.10 schreiben aber hat es
dann irgendwie verpennt oder das ging
nicht und am 11.10 auch vergessen und am
12 dachte sie ach komm dann kommt es
doppelt sympathisch dass du sogar eine
12 von 10 ist den emoji habe ich no job
noch nie verstanden also was bedeutet
der jetzt mal no joke for real ich kann
mir halt vorstellen dass es ein ist der
gerade irgendwie so eine Rauchwolke
ausatmet es kann auch jemand sein der in
der Kälte sich denkt boah wo ist das
kalt es kann aber auch jemand sein von
wegen oh ist das cool und nice und wild
und ich mache weiter Spruch kannst du
uns vielleicht mal in Mannheim besuchen
kommen denn wir haben hier nur den
Wasserturm als Sehenswürdigkeit und mit
dir hätten wir dann eine zweite danke
schön
ich weiß zwar nicht ob ich so
sehenswürdig bin und ganz komischer
Begriff ne
Sehenswürdigkeit da kann man sich doch
bestimmt irgendwas besseres in der
deutschen Sprache ausdenkt deutsche
Sprache schwere Sprache darf ich mal
deine Wurst sehen bitte einfach mal
direkt auf den Punkt kommen
ich wusste nicht dass Mädels wirklich so
krass im Flirt Game unterwegs ich dachte
nur Typen sind so dumm falls du gerade
auf dem Weg zum Puff warst wollte ich
dir nur kurz sagen dass du bei mir was
sparen kannst Bro Bro ich würde gerne
Liebe mit dir machen das genauso wie der
wurstspruch einfach so direkt Mistgabel
nehmen rein da darf ich heute bei dir
schlafen ich habe nämlich leider aus
Versehen in mein Bett geschickt ja
Zehner ich sie schreibt ihr jetzt ey ja
du klingst nach einem cleanen Girl Alter
lass mal was zu machen hätte aber auch
von mir sein können der Spruch ich
verfolge dich schon seit längerem und
liebe deine dummen Instagram Stories auf
jeden Fall habe ich schon häufig gesehen
dass im Garten deine Eltern oft
Eichhörnchen rumlaufen ich denke jetzt
mal nicht dass du Angst vor diesen
kleinen Nagetieren haben wirst wenn du
allerdings doch Angst vor denen hast
kannst du deine Eichel gern auch bei mir
verstecken
das ist wirklich unterste Schublade die
Schublade hier ist das
ich bin Gärtnerin und kann deine Gurke
zum Waschen bringen ich glaube sie mein
wachsen aber
es ist alles anonym aber ich weiß ganz
genau dass diese Person keine Gärtnerin
ist ich kann es jetzt nicht sagen was
diese Person macht oder keine Ahnung
weil dann weiß man vielleicht was das
für eine Person ist aber das ist
fremdschämt Hasch Bock mal wieder was zu
starten wie damals meine ich und diese
Person habe ich noch nie gesehen
ich habe schon oft gehabt dass Leute mir
bei Whatsapp geschrieben haben weil sie
von keine Ahnung woher meine
Telefonnummer bekommen haben und mich
dann angeschrieben haben von wegen hey
äh sorry ich hatte Dich nicht mehr
eingespeichert wie geht's dir so läuft
noch alles bei dir die wollten mir dann
psychologisch unterbewusst klar machen
von wegen ey luca du kennst mich ja
eigentlich aber ich kenne die gar nicht
die für Tricks hier drauf haben ne
wahnsinn ich finde da muss man schon
durchschnaufen ja ich heiße zwar nicht
Madison aber ein Bier hätte ich dennoch
für dich der stark wir können uns ja
vielleicht mal connecten bei Bier bin
ich immer dabei wenn ich mir dich so
angucke muss ich echt kotzen weil ich
allergisch gegen heiße Typen bin
kurz mal schön alleine weiter wohne auch
in Köln wollen wir rummachen ich habe
zwar keinen rum aber wir können rum
machen
also nicht du ich aber der Spruch war
gut und das ist ein Dokument gewesen den
ich egal ich kann lesen das in deiner
Hose was für mich steht
ich bin so unfassbar schlecht im Bett
das musst Du erlebt haben ich weiß dass
ich die Dinger rausgesucht habe aber da
sind wirklich Sachen dabei die habe ich
vor zwei Wochen oder so geschickt
bekommen und das jetzt einfach noch mal
so stumpf zu lesen da denkt sich eine
Person wirklich nachts vielleicht hatte
sie gerade in One Night Stand mit dem
Typen und er ist abgehauen und dann
meinte sie so jetzt schreib mal Luca das
ist egal habe gerade mit meiner Freundin
heute einen neuen Podcast gehört und wir
haben dich leider an einer Stelle nicht
richtig verstanden kannst du eventuell
zu uns nach Hause kommen und nutzt das
noch mal persönlich erklären ja klar
bin gleich bei euch freut mich schon
soll ich noch irgendwie Champagner
mitbringen oder sowas wenn du ein Apfel
wärst dann wärst Du einen Granatapfel no
joke man kann sich hier echt ein paar
Sprüche aufschreiben ich kann euch allen
nur empfehlen wenn ihr verzweifelt
Single seid macht euch jetzt schon eine
Notiz auf eurem Handy wo ihr einerseits
Sprüche rein schreibt wo ihr aber auch
Unternehmungen reinschreibt für ein
erstes Date wo ihr aber vielleicht auch
Gerichte rein schreibt und dass wenn ihr
dann ursprünglich plötzlich euch
irgendwie verlieben sollte dass ihr alle
Informationen direkt parat habt
Jeremy Style immer organisiert sein oh
du kennst mich zwar nicht aber glaub mir
du würdest richtig gerne in meiner Haut
stecken hey komm nehmen einfach weiter
na auch hier nee
in meinen Ems da bin ich nicht du magst
zwar keinen Kaffee aber hast du
vielleicht trotzdem eine Latte für mich
egal
dann kannst du nicht ausdenken ne du
kannst dir das nicht ausdenken ich
schwöre bei Gott hier ist nichts Fake
oder was weiß ich dass du Nachrichten
die ich bekommen habe auf meinem Account
ich schwöre das ist so peinlich aber
irgendwie auch kreativ tun dir deine
Beine eigentlich gar nicht weg oder wie
wollte sie glaube ich schreiben weil du
gehst mir nicht mehr aus dem Kopf
bitte einfach abschalten der Buchstabe ü
sieht aus wie ich wenn ich dich sehe
weil ich dann immer so breit grinsen
muss weil ich dich so hübsch finde
plötzlich immer ein ach so sie meint
glaube ich dass die Pünktchen oben die
Augen sind und das U dann ganz lang
gezogenes Gesicht ich kann nicht genau
sagen was das für Mädel ist ne ich war
besoffen und hat sich vertippt irgendwie
und hat aus Versehen so ein großes ü
geschrieben als ich dann gedacht äh
witzig ja und weiter hat sie dann
wahrscheinlich nicht gedacht eigentlich
koste ich was aber für dich wäre ich
auch kostenlos und ich sag euch nojoko
das ist einfach eine plus 18
Darstellerin die mir das geschrieben hat
entspannt Bruder wenn du eine Kartoffel
wärst wärst du eine Süßkartoffel das ist
aber gut finde ich das sind nicer Spruch
aber no joke das sei jetzt auch ganz
ehrlich ich bin aktuell an nichts
interessiert wieder so one night
standmäßig noch letzte neue Beziehung
oder keine Ahnung was ich weiß ich mache
da manchmal jokes drüber auf humorvoller
Art und Weise weil es einfach auf witzig
ist wir machen weiter dann seht ihr mal
was hier noch so für Schwachsinn am
Start war deine Zähne sind wie Sterne
gelb und weit auseinander korrekt dicker
darauf antworte ich definitiv da du ja
auch genauso wie wir lol einen Podcast
bei Spotify hast wollte ich dich kurz
mal fragen ob du derzeit auch Probleme
mit den Charts hast bei mir wirst du
nämlich gar nicht als heißeste Single
der Woche gelistet Digger die haben
einfach auch ein Podcast ich kann euch
Tipp geben die sind in den Top 100 und
das als Anmachspruch auszuhauen ich
wollte schon no joke fragen ob sie mal
bei uns im Podcast mit dabei sein will
aber das ist glaube ich dann ein
bisschen unangenehm der Spruch trotzdem
gut ich bin zwar kein influencer wenn du
mich allerdings mal besuchen würdest
könntest du Influenza sein oh Gott war
der schlecht zu Info sie heißt fluenza
mit Vornamen nein doch da hätte ich am
liebsten darauf geantwortet hat gesagt
ey Komma mach dein Ding kein Interesse
aber der Spruch ist stark weil klar
Äußerlichkeiten Aussehen Körper etc das
wichtig aber Humor und innere Werte ist
auch wichtig und für mich ist Humor
extrem wichtig und da hat sie durch
diesen Spruch alleine mit zehn von zehn
bei mir gelandet ich bin eine Praline
die gern gefüllt werden würde ne komm
weiter geht's ich war heute in der Stadt
unterwegs und habe da irgendwie meine
Handynummer verloren kann ich vielleicht
deine haben oh da kommt was was Großes
oh mein Gott das war der peinlichste
Furz den ich in der Mikrofon gesetzt
habe ich bin am Wochenende mit meinen
Mädels in Kölle und hätte zwischen nicht
noch so zehn Minuten Zeit und 20 cm
Platz für dich nee jetzt spaß beiseite
wir sind im Nachtflug feiern am Samstag
also kommen wir noch mit Sandy Bier geht
auf uns Alter dabei sehen wir uns
Samstag Nachtflug nee ich glaube schon
eine Woche alt oder so egal jetzt ich
mache alles wieder gut
oh ja der stinkt auch kommen wir nun
allerdings auch schon zum letzten
Anmachspruch meiner lieben Freunde und
ihr seht schon hier eingeblendet die
Uhrzeit gestern 3:28 Uhr mitten in der
Nacht hat mir eine Person Sturz besoffen
dass sie geschrieben hey Luca ganz
ehrlich hätte ich noch viel getrunken
heute würde ich dir viele gut gar nicht
scriven aber ich finde Tieren noch cool
von dir dass du ganz online bist kannst
dich ja melden uff you want if not meld
dich trotzdem
an der Stelle geht einfach nur ein
riesige shoutout raus an die Luke Crew
meine Community danke für euren
jahrelang Support an eure unfassbar
krasse Kreativität im Thema
Anmachsprüche oder deine Mädels da
draußen die anscheinend irgendwie ein
bisschen verzweifelt auf der Suche sind
nach Schwein euch das Video gefallen hat
lass gern Daumen hoch unter dem Video da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke um weitere Videos nicht
verpassen und ich habe noch einen für
euch
wow da kam definitiv